the gomu gumunomi is not what you think
it is there's a reason why shanks went
out of his way to steal the fruit and a
reason why it makes luffy so special and
now it's time to find out what it is
because maybe shanks use the fruit to
determine the man who can bring the dawn
or maybe just maybe it's not actually
the gomu gomonomi after all but a
mythical zone devil fruit
hi there my name is manu and as you can
tell i've been on a bit of a streak
lately with the videos on luffy even
though zoro is my favorite character
luffy is not far behind for me and i've
made several videos about why i think
he's the best written shonen protagonist
out there but recent events in one piece
had me obsessed about luffy's true
nature and powers and how oda is clearly
teasing us with something about luffy
that he's deliberately holding back
right now for the longest time it seemed
to me like luffy eating the gomu
gomunomi was merely a coincidence he was
just hanging out with shanks and his men
who had brought the fruit with them and
while they were looking away luffy took
it as a nice little snack in between
good for you luffy eating healthy later
shanks apparently on a whim saw
something special in luffy so he
motivated him to become a pirate and
gave him his hat as inspiration
and it was only thanks to luffy's
immense creativity that the gumo
gomunomi seemed more than average at
best to me as a power now everything has
seemed to have changed and to me this
first chapter of one piece seems filled
to the brim with foreshadowing and set
up for the end game of the story but
looking at all that i have to share with
you in this video it's so exciting that
i really can't complain okay so with
odin's flashback we've gotten a lot of
new insights into the workings of roger
and his journey to love tale shanks has
turned out to be one of the most
influential characters in the story with
ties to roger the other yonko and even
the gorosei instead of being a pirate
that likes to party and drink most of
the time he's the man pulling the
strings on political developments and
the future of the world and
still likes to party most of the time
[Music]
as you might already know i'm convinced
that shanks did not simply show up in
fuchsia village because he was aimlessly
sailing around the east blue shanks was
extremely close to roger and even
inherited his precious straw hat and now
we know that roger and his man came to
love tail too early and that the pirate
king was waiting for the one who could
bring the dawn
world
that's exactly the reason why he created
the new pirate era in the first place to
inspire as many people as possible to
find it he then ordered his men to find
the right person and guide that person
towards the last island to find the one
piece i'm convinced that that is why
rayleigh was waiting at the entrance to
the new world as the only one able to
coat ships keeping a close eye on
everyone who came through and
immediately recognized luffy for who he
was
[Music]
the reason why crocus was guarding the
entrance to the grand line at reverse
mountain where he surely recognized
luffy the same way and made sure he
found his way onwards i'm pretty sure he
didn't give out a free log post to
everyone and explain them how to use it
[Music]
and finally shanks was tasked with
finding the right member of the d family
not blackbeard to inherit roger's will i
would bet my favorite coffee mug that
shanks actually came to fuja village to
find ace not luffy the son of his former
captain who was determined on having a
son of his own to succeed
and it's the same reason he left right
away never to be seen in the east blue
again right after entrusting luffy with
roger's hat and sacrificing his arm to
ensure he would become the one who could
bring the dawn whether he actually knew
how powerful luffy would become and how
fast and who his parents were i don't
know however i will make videos on both
luffy's possible powers of the wano and
who his mother might be very soon so if
you want to see those and are a true mad
lad please consider subscribing to the
channel and now with recent chapters
speculation around devil fruits and more
specifically luffy's devil fruit has
gotten a lot of fresh winds from here on
out spoil a warning if you're not caught
up to the story yet honestly i was
completely shocked when i found out from
who's who that shanks did not simply
stumble across the specific devil fruit
but went out of his way to steal it from
the world government itself while it was
protected by the likes of cp9 that
together with the reveal of sun god nika
also by who's who which will actually be
important later on and so this now backs
the question to me whether shanks didn't
just choose luffy as the next possible
pirate king because he reminded him of
roger but because luffy smacked on the
most important fruit in the entire story
and so i now want to discuss with you
all the exciting possibilities for what
could possibly make a rubber devil fruit
so special but before we eat dessert
let's first have some veggies let's
assume that the fruit isn't special
after all why did shanks go out of his
way to risk war with the government to
steal it if it wasn't super duper
important to him okay so one possibility
could be that shanks actually made a bit
of a whoopsie when stealing the fruit
since he seems to have been the only one
to be aware of how dangerous blackbeard
truly is he might well have been aware
of his connections to rox diesel back or
wherever teach got the idea for the yami
yami no me from
and so maybe the government simply
mistook the gomu gomi for its much more
powerful counterpart and information
about that leaked through to shanks and
then only after stealing the fruit did
he actually realize that he had not
gotten his hand on the yami yami no meme
after all another possibility i could
see is that one of the celestial dragons
had purchased luffy's fruit for a lot of
money madonna wanted to use it on one of
your slaves i guess or whatever weird
thing they do
which is why cp9 was specifically
instructed with its transport but i
personally think that oda wouldn't have
gone out of his way to bring shanks
stealing the fruit from the government
up like this if it weren't important in
some way or four as i discussed in my
character analysis of shanks he's
usually someone that avoids fighting a
conflict at all costs trying to be like
the mediator with pirates and the
gorosei alike
so i feel there must be something very
special about the gomu gomonomi for him
to actually attack a government ship i
do think that the fruit is special in
some way or form and shanks used it to
find the next joyboy so once luffy had
eaten it there was literally no
alternative for him but to bet
everything on luffy what could possibly
be so special about it i think there are
three different options here number one
number one it's not about the fruit
itself but who wielded it before luffy
number two the fruit actually has a
hidden power that makes it way more
powerful and dangerous than it appears
or number three the name of luffy's
devil fruit is actually not the gumu
gumo nomi at all but actually a
legendary zone fruit let's start with
one this is based on a theory of mine
about the true nature of devil fruits
that i've shared before if you want to
hear my full line of reasoning and proof
for it i suggest you check out that
video after but here's what you need to
know it seems like devil fruits possess
a will of their own some sort of spirit
that belongs to the devil that gives its
user their powers this seems to be very
likely as we've already seen inanimate
objects gaining consciousness by eating
a devil fruit and we do know that the
soul is a real and important thing in
one piece from brooks and big mom's
abilities alike another major theme in
one piece is that of inherited will and
so i suspect that when someone eats a
devil fruit they merge with their own
soul and once the user dies a part of
them lives on in that devil fruit then
when someone else consumes the fruit
they seem to take on some traits of the
previous user we have for instance seen
this with sabo after eating aces fruit
saying and doing the same things and
using the same abilities even though
sabo never really saw ace use the fruit
before
big mom who behaves a lot like mother
caramel after consuming her fruit
the point i'm trying to make here is
that the gomu gomunomi might have
belonged to someone very important
someone whose will luffy now has
inherited the prime two candidates here
of course roger and joy boy roger
possibly finding the fruit on love tale
eating it and then passing away
relatively soon after without anyone
ever knowing and indeed only shortly
after eating the fruit luffy starts
saying the exact same things as roger
something he keeps doing throughout the
story
so maybe luffy inherited rogers or joy
boy's will through the gomu gomu no me
and that's why it's so important to
shanks one thing that i think is really
important to address here if the fruit
is that important why didn't shanks eat
it himself well he stated at some point
in the story that neither he nor any of
his crew would eat a devil fruit since
they all needed to swim i'm not sure why
and what that means but i feel it will
be important at some points hey everyone
just while editing the video i've
realized that i completely forgot to
plug my new subreddit that i just
launched it's called wild anime theories
a place where you can share your best
animated manga theories we're gonna take
the best one of these turn them into
videos for a brand new channel that's
launching in february oh and we're also
hiring two people a script writer and a
thumbnail artist for the new channel as
well so check out the applications in
the description below if you're
interested i do write all my scripts
here myself but for the new channel i
think that'll just be too much so just
make sure to check it out after you
watch this video the link is in the
description below and let's keep rolling
with the video now okay number two the
fruit has a hidden power that we don't
yet know about a possibility here is
that the gumu gomu nomi might be the
perfect counter to another fruit we've
already seen this happen with nl who
also wielded an incredibly powerful
fruit
[Music]
and so another good fit for it could be
the guraguranomi the strongest paramecia
fruit currently wielded by blackbeard in
theory luffy's awakening might be the
perfect counter to blackbeard's
abilities robert doesn't break after all
and luffy as sun god nika is the natural
enemy of blackbeard's darkness anyway
one problem with this idea however is
that the guru guru no me obviously was
still in possession of whitebeard 12
years ago so only if shanks already knew
that blackbeard was after the fruit
would that make actual sense but then
again who knows maybe the previous user
was rocks and shanks suspected
blackbeard would try to gain it for
himself at some point as well
then again on second thought maybe the
power is not really related to another
devil fruit but what it just can't do on
its own maybe the gomu gomonomi in some
way or form is the key to changing the
world some ability you will need on loft
tail to unlock the one piece one idea of
how this might become relevant is
luffy's gear third ability that enlarges
his body into that of a giant and as you
know there is a lot of interest in
gigantification in one piece everyone
wants them literally the government big
mom and even kaido with the numbers and
in general giants appear a lot in
connection to past events we have a d
giant with saul we have the giant frozen
straw hat in marijuana and we have even
seen a giant with luffy's personality
with oars
so it's quite possible that luffy's
fruit might allow him to turn into a
giant which might be the key to bringing
the dawn the third option is probably my
favorite one though i have to say up
front even for my standards it is a bit
of a stretch since we're talking about
luffy here though that might actually be
okay and it really is an incredibly fun
one to think about this theory is by a
reddit user called the biggest wheel i
don't know maybe a wheel of time
reference there who proposes that the
fruit the gorosei are discussing in
chapter 1037
is actually luffy's and that the gomu
gomo nomi is just a name that the
government came up with to erase its
true nature from history the base of
this theory is luffy's resemblance with
the wisdom king myo as well as the
introduction of sango nikata
[Music]
both of these gods can be linked to
luffy and the idea then is that luffy
actually ate the mythical zone devil
fruit of the wisdom king some sort of
buddhist deity in this case basically
luffy's rubber abilities stay the same
however they're just part of his
creature just like the healing ability
for markers phoenix
and going off of the latest chapter that
this fruit hasn't awakened in centuries
the author then argues that the original
owner of this fruit might have been the
very person that was seen as god nika in
other words joy boy himself and so maybe
luffy is just awakening this very unique
devil fruit right now i mean the design
of gear fourth is so fundamentally
different from anything we've seen so
far from luffy not only does he
literally resemble a wisdom king but he
has three forms of gear fourth just like
zone fruit users have multiple forms as
we can see with chopper however the key
to this is really another unexplained
power that luffy has
redhawk has been pretty much a mystery
ever since luffy was able to use it and
now we actively see him using his
firepowers and it's the only attack
kaido has bothered dodging so far wisdom
kings are usually depicted with fiery
hair just as the sun god nika seems to
be anoda actually once made this street
fighter ken version of luffy but ken
clearly doesn't have fire here that is
actually an addition made by oda and the
design of the wisdom king pops up a lot
throughout one piece we have eno who
pretends to be a god this figure during
the fire festival and of course king who
has fire powers as well and comes from a
race of alleged gods nika and the wisdom
king shandora and wano two nations
closely connected through yes their
history and their ties to the ancient
kingdom so i guess the craziest but most
exciting option here is that shanks
stole the gomu gomunomi because in
reality it is one of the strongest devil
fruits out there and belonged to joy boy
himself
but even if we assume that the gomu
gomunomi is just the rubber fruit there
are still a lot of great possibilities
for luffy's awakening and there's a lot
more to learn about devil fruits in
general so check out either of the two
of these two videos
right here